[Music]
americans held hostage behind enemy
lines day 111.
welcome to hannity this news breaking
friday night it is now day 111.
that's right since joe biden abandoned
our fellow americans trapped in
afghanistan including military families
hundreds of them thousands of green card
holders and of course our afghan allies
something he said 13 days earlier he'd
never do joe biden has turned the page
the mob and the medias turn the page we
will not we will remind everybody until
they are home safely now of course this
is one of many self-inflicted crises
that biden is unwilling incapable of
resolving now breaking earlier more
really bad news for americans the
november jobs report was a disaster
abysmal falling way short of every
projection keep in mind we are already
facing a severe worker shortage in the
country we now have record-setting
inflation at 31-year high you're now
paying on average about a buck 50 more a
gallon that's 20 25 30 bucks more every
time you fill up your tank we're paying
a fortune now to heat and cool our homes
and everything you buy in every store
you go to is costing more because of joe
biden's stagnant growth and now it is
getting worse but don't take my word for
it let's look at cnbc the u.s economy
created far fewer jobs than expected in
november in a sign that hiring started
to slow ahead of the new coveted threat
but today biden proudly announced that
this was quote incredible news and that
our economic recovery is going strong
what world are you living in joe now i
thought biden promised to shut down the
virus not the economy what happened now
one big problem for joe is you just
can't lie your way out of a crisis
americans are suffering look at the
gallup poll today we'll get into that in
a minute and the truth be told it
doesn't appear that joe can do much of
anything at this point in his life he's
frail he's weak he's confused he's
confounded he's mumbling he's a bumbling
cognitive mess and even a simple tree
lighting that became a massive struggle
you can't make this up either take a
look
and now it is my tremendous honor
to welcome
our literal host the actual host for
this very american celebration
president biden and first lady dr jill
biden
[Music]
we want to do it again
and now
it's my tremendous honor to welcome our
real hosts our literal host for this
very american celebration president
biden and first lady dr jill body
[Applause]
[Music]
i speak from here
two minutes and 19 seconds
wow now what on earth were they doing
now that guy is supposed to be running
the most powerful country on earth and
he's supposed to be the leader of the
free world meanwhile his second in
command kamala harris is the most
unpopular vice president in history and
third in line to be president well
that's nancy pelosi she's 81 she is the
single most powerful person in the house
of representatives but of course she's
controlled by the real speaker
congresswoman ocasio-cortez and she too
meaning nancy pelosi is also a cognitive
mess take a look at this clip i don't
know how i miss this from a couple of
weeks ago and ask yourself
what is nancy pelosi actually trying to
say to us take a look
well it's
most of the product that we've done is
except now
we may have had it in the last day or so
and some of what we added is senate
to the bill like a hearing
bernie doesn't like hearing
excuse me bernie loves hearing
so um
so we are getting some
bird and privilege
i think i think mostly we're getting
privileged scrub because privileged drug
is deadly to a bill vertical
is important is you have to take it out
we want to be sure that what we send
is not bird-able or
bird bath
or
privileged scrub
they're the two
exercises we're getting engaged
bathing exercises we're engaged in
god help this country in the world um i
think nancy may have also been in
washington a bit too long how is it
possible that we now have two of the
most powerful people in washington
both being equally incoherent both
struggling cognitively and supposedly
they're running the country this is
frightening the two most powerful jobs
in america being filled by people who
can barely form a cogent sentence it's
scary and guess what every hostile
regime every enemy country and every
hostile actor they see what we see and
then to make matters worse joe biden is
now apparently physically sick with some
kind of nasal something going on today
he can barely speak and he's been
hacking up a lung now for a couple of
days take a look
before i start i'd like to report that
later today i'll be signing the bill
funding the government operations for
the next few months
simply put
america america's back to work
since the end of october excuse me the
average in partnership with business
excuse me with private business and
labor
retailers
and grocery stores freight movers and
railroads
for example at the port of los angeles
and long beach
the two busiest ports in america and
they're ready to meet consumer demand
for the holidays
i said that yesterday
i almost want to put on my mask watching
it
now we hope joe feels better and isn't
seriously ill now today biden assured us
that he was not suffering from covert 19
but told our own peter ducey that he
picked up a cold from kissing his
grandson blame the kid take a look
first of all mr president uh your voice
sounds a little different are you okay
i'm okay i have a test every day to see
a kova test i've been checking for all
the strands what i have is a one and a
half year old grandson who had a cold
who likes to kiss his pop
and he'd been kissing my anyway so uh
but it's just a cold